we honor the legacy of jackie robinson
who's number 42 has been retired by
major league baseball in perpetuity his
contributions and his legacy will never
be forgotten and we celebrate that and
our national pastime in atlanta today
and ian anderson 22 years old 6-3 170
out of rexford new york will make his
third start his last outing
against philadelphia no decision five
and a third innings five hits four runs
and gets a man to chase there that's ian
anderson at his best dickerson didn't
get it and anderson has his first
strikeout one away
that's a good change up
talked about it a lot last night jeff
you don't have to make a hall of fame
pitch to get strike two or strike three
just make it look good enough to get a
swing and a miss
and it worked cooper chases a high
fastball and that will retire the side
yeah good matchup hottest hitter on the
planet versus a guy who's very confident
throwing the ball well he's got a
fastball in the mid 90s
good slider to 83 and one of the reasons
he's been so successful in two starts
this year righties are hitting two for
23 off him
97 miles an hour and kind of doing
exactly what garcia did just pumping the
heat no wasting time right i love when
pitchers go at hitters after they foul a
ball off their foot and it's a good time
to do it 97 miles an hour you just
challenge him to put that behind him
next up is jazz chisholm
this is jazz to left extra bases for
jazz chisholm jr with one out in the
second inning in scoring position for
john bertie
right side fair ball this should be a
run john birdie can fly he's on his way
to second base with an rbi double
bertie getting it done again
i've seen it time and time again
throughout his career i mean gets the
start and jumps right into the lineup
and produces
elevated fastball freddie freeman no
shot at it
great piece of hitting everyone's doing
bertie a favor though he loves to go the
other way and it's a one-nothing marlins
lead chad wallach that's a base hit
bernie rounding third he's gonna come in
to score they'll test the arm of ozuna
bertie's gonna win that one just about
every single time two nothing miami and
the wallach family loving every second
of it yeah while it getting it done i
i'll tell you why this is a great swing
but john birdie had to hold up at second
base to see that this ball got through
and then decided to run on osuna anyway
and ozuna took his time i mean my
goodness
bertie's just now hitting third base as
soon as got the baseball
wow
how about a 406 hitter with the grand
slam with the bases loaded for aguilar
1-0 [ __ ]
smoke toward third reilly drops it picks
it up slow man running in panic and
freeman with a stretch
and that will retire the side hard hit
ball by aguilar miami strikes for two in
the second here's ozzy alves to the
plate
albie's out to shallow center it's gonna
be birdie making an acrobatic play in
center field
how did he get there and how did he hang
on
the speed on display again
like a wide receiver at the back of the
end zone are you kidding me
he got both feet down yeah he did one
two he got him down he got him down
wow what a catch
he took his eye off the ball for a split
second too
wow
prayer answered pal prayer answered
wallach wants it up missed a spot
he gets the strikeout anyway going to
the top of the fourth inning ian
anderson will go back to work trailing
two to nothing
is caught on a missed came back and got
him with a fastball five strikeouts for
anderson he's now set down five in a row
rogers drops down the bunt it's going to
be riley and a sacrifice for rogers
moving wallach up to second a runner in
scoring position for corey dickerson
dickerson a base hit wallock coming
around third he is going to score
dickerson with an rbi single and the
marlins stretched their lead to three
nothing
well we give so much praise corey's
direction right for being patient and
grinding out at bats well not this
afternoon he's last two at bats he's
seeing two pitches and he's lined them
both into right field this is going to
produce another run great swing
how long he stays in the hitting zone
just a really nice stroke
makes that sacrifice bunt stand up it's
albies and then swanson and riley here
in the fourth that's right that's a
called strike three bottom of the zone
five strikeouts for rogers
there's a shot to right cooper
watches that carry over his head he
broke in a step and that cost him
there goes the no-hitter and atlanta
will
see dansby swanson stop at second base
with his fourth two base hit watson at
second with the double heredia the
runner at first the ball in two strikes
and two outs to alex jackson and his
swing and a miss he beats him with the
fastball up and out of the zone six
strikeouts through four braves first
piece off the bench is adrianza
that one off the glove of jazz chisholm
lost his cap and adrian's is aboard
there's a start for atlanta that's the
first time the leadoff man has reached
so to the top we go ronald lacuna junior
the hitter he is oh for two
first pitch swing high fly ball left
field dickerson going back to the
warning track that ball is gone a
majestic home run for acuna
and just like that
the braves are back in the game his
unbelievable month continues
i said it before you can't keep relying
on ronald but
dad gum if he doesn't do it again
and this was what we're talking about
watch this pitch in a minute you're
going to see inside fastball chip and as
we said last year he was either missing
that
could get to it
he broke his back the first two times
today on that pitch
if you've got secretariat in the stable
you'd be foolish not to ride it
and as we head to the home sixth inning
on this lovely afternoon swanson wiley
and heredia are coming up against zach
popp oh
that did pop heredia
and pablo sandoval is indeed going to
come up and pinch it
[Applause]
first pitch swing fly ball left
dickerson back pablo
he did get something fastball right out
over the zone you gotta like it
he said i gotta be aggressive if i get
my pitch
[Applause]
send to the marlins bullpen now to give
the braves a 5-3 lead
the kung fu panda
[Applause]
third pitch hit homer
marte aguilar and cooper here against
jones
that's in the air left field starling
martay with a home run into the bullpen
a one run game in the seventh as martay
goes deep
and it did not take long
marlin saw jones a little earlier in the
series
great swing from marta short compact
stroke good extension look at the finish
a no doubter into the bullpen aj minter
is on to try to close down a one-run
game let's hope aj puts his last downing
against the marlins in the
memory vault
all the way to the backstop
and a lead off walk in a 5-4 game and
now you've got duvall to contend
and with ball out to right field that is
going to get down into the gap all the
way to the wall mickey's on his way to
third he's coming home
relay throw is cut off and adam duvall
does it again to his former club we are
tied in the ninth
have yourself a series adam duvall
my goodness
what a great at bat battles back from
two strikes down got an elevated
fastball and goes with it
coupe bats with duval at second two outs
sharpie hit into center field of base
hit around third is duvall he's going to
score and garrett cooper comes through
more big hits
late in games for the marlins in this
series
and how about coop if you think back to
extra innings in game one coop was the
hero late a big three-hit performance
lines a single into center duvall is
going to come around and score easily
and the marlins have come all the way
back another two out run for the marlins
so it's dylan floro he will get the save
opportunity in this one he has been very
good
out of the marlins bullpen in the early
going of this 2021 season
and turns it loose and gives up an 02
single to left
that's something ender's been working on
since the spring hit it the other way
and he got an o2 count and took
advantage
line drive over short that's down for a
base hit first and second nobody out
a austin bases are loaded
nobody's out running it back
he walked it
game is tied on a bases loaded walk
celebratory water bottles ready if
dansby can make some contact and bring
home acuna who's now 90 feet away
[Applause]
and the braves come back again and beat
the marlins in game four it's a 7-6
final